Good morning Hank; it’s Monday. Today’s
video is like Voldemort’s soul: It comes
to you in seven parts.
Part one: Butler. Hank, my hometown Butler
Bulldogs are in the men’s basketball final
four for the second consecutive year, an astonishing
achievement that looked like this at the bar
where I watched the game.
(Incoherent cheering and screaming, John jostles
the camera a lot and screams.)
I watched all the previous rounds at home,
they mostly looked like this: Matt Howard,
your sister is a Nerdfighter, you can hit
this free throw, you can! YES! (John sits
on Elmo, who says something) You’re ruining
it, Elmo. You’re ruining it.
By the way, Hank, Butler star Matt Howard’s
sister Laura really is a Nerdfighter. Sports
and Nerdfighteria, Hank, the connections are
endless.
Part two: Brandishing. Hank, on twitter Samisemicolon
writes “I love when at realjohngreen brandishes
random things like black Santas in his videos.”
Brandish. Brandish. Brandish!
Part three: a definition. Hank, it belatedly
occurs to me that some Nerdfighters might
not even know what basketball is, so let me
define it. Basically there’s two hollow
cylinders and one sphere and you’re trying
to put the sphere in one of the hollow cylinders
without having it go in the other hollow cylinder.
It’s essentially participatory geometry.
Part four: Finalists. So Hank, this sparkly
little number "Will Grayson, Will Grayson,"
which I co-wrote, is a finalist for the Children’s
Book Choice Award. Hank, actual teenagers
pick the winner of this award, so if you are
an actual teenager go to the link in the doobly-do
and vote for your favorite book of the year.
Also also also I just learned that my new
book is definitely coming out in March! Not
like, in the next two days, but, you know,
we got another March that’s gonna come around.
That one. Ohhh, I should probably settle on
a title soon.
Part five: an imaginary conversation with
Lebron James. Hi Lebron James, so what do
you do for a living? “I insert spheres into
cylinders!” Wow, that sounds extremely tedious
and probably not very lucrative. “Actually
it’s incredibly fun and I make millions
of dollars.” Huh. I wouldn’t have thought
that job pays well.
Part six: Titles. So Hank, Nerdfighteria generated
more than two thousand titles for my new book,
many of which were very good, but none of
which I’m going to use. My original title
idea was to call the book “The Hectic Glow”
after the great Thoreau quote “decay and
disease are often beautiful, like the pearly
tear of the shellfish or the hectic glow of
consumption”, but the problem with “The
Hectic Glow” is that it’s like the rural
juror of book titles. You say it and people
are like “What? The Metric Snow? The Hectic
Blow?” I don’t want people to think I
wrote a book called the Hectic Blow! Then
I thought I might call it “Omnis Cellula
e Cellula” and the nice folks at Penguin
were like, “You know what doesn’t smell
like a bestseller? Latin.” So I still don’t
have a firm title. If you have any new suggestions,
feel free to leave them in comments.
Part seven: “Sports is like life also poop”
is a great quote from Esther. Anyway, Hank,
I would argue that sports matter. So like
if you’re really into Harry Potter and you
got an email from JK Rowling, that would be
amazing, right? Like imagine that moment.
That would be a great moment. But for some
people those awesome moments are different,
like the Cubs winning the World Series or
a bunch of unheralded kids from a liberal
arts school in Indiana going to the Final
Four.
Hank, we choose what we care about, and while
there are better and worse choices, I would
argue that caring about sports has nothing
to do with Lebron James or participatory geometry.
Ultimately, it’s about community. I’d
argue that caring about sports is actually
a lot like caring about Harry Potter or Dungeons
and Dragons or Nerdfighteria. Caring about
stuff binds us to the other people who care
about that stuff, and that creates the communities
that make life worth living.
So Hank, that’s my defense of sports. Go
Bulldogs! I’ll see you on Wednesday.